ضربات جويه في سوريا ردا على هجوم سابق
استهدف جنودا امريكيين
يحضر الاوروبيين بان تاخر في ارسال
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا سيعطيل امد الحرب
الولايات المتحده تفرض قيودا على اربعه
عشره شركات صينيه تستورد التكنولوجيا
الامريكيه
اعتقال 82 محتجا في باريس واصابه اكثر من
130 عنصر امن بمظاهره مليونيه ضد قانون
التقاعد
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره لاهم الانباء من العربيه قالت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه في بيان لها ان الجيش
الامريكي نفذ ضربات جويه في الحسكه شمال
شرق سوريا ردا على هجوم سابق استهدف
جنودنا امريكيين والدائه الى اصابه خمسه
منهم ومقتل متعاقد في الهجوم الذي نفذ
بطائره مسيره
نقلت وكاله تاسر روسيه على النائب رئيس
المركز الروسي للمصالحه في سوريا اوليج
غورنوف ان عدد الانتهاكات المرتبطه
بالطائرات المسيره وطائرات الحربيه
التابعه للتحالف الدولي بقياده واش طب في
سوريا تزايدت بشكل ملحوظ مقارنه بالعام
السابق جرينو اعتبر ان اعضاء التحالف
يواصلون انتهاك بروتوكولات منع وقوع
الاشتباكات والمذكره الثنائيه بشان سلامه
الرحلات الجويه في سوريا مشيرا الى ان هذه
الانتهاكات متعمده ومتكرره
وفاه البرصاد السوري بان تنظيم داعش قتل
سبعه مدنيين في ريف حماه شرقي موضحا ان
المدنيين قاتلوا ذبحا على يد خلايا
التنظيم اثناء جمعهم الكما في المنطقه
الواقعه بين جرف مارينا وحريبه وحريبه
سلبيه شرقي حماه وبحسب المرصد تعتبر
الكماه مصدر رزق مهم للمواطنين
وجه
الرئيسكي كلمه اتسمت بالحده لقاده الاتحاد
الاوروبي حث فيها اوروبا على تعزيز
امدادات الاسلحه الحديثه والتعجيل
بارسالها وفرض عقوباتنا شده صرابه على
روسيا قال انه في حال انتظرت اوروبا
سيتوفر لروسيا الوقت لتعيد جمع صفوفها
والاستعداد لسنوات من الحرب مذكرا ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي هو الذي ارجع القرارات
بشان توفير اسلحه بعيده المدى وطائرات
مقاتله حديثه والمضي قدما في محادثات منح
اوكرانيا عضويه في الحلف
وشكى من ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يسارع
فيما يبدو بفرض مزيد من العقوبات على
روسيا
تصريحاته جاءت بعد نكد قاده الاتحاد
الاوروبي تمسكهم بالنظام الدولي متعدد
الاطراف وعرضوا في اجتماع استضافوا فيه
امين عام الامم المتحده التزامهم مواصله
السعي لنيل دعم المجموعه الدوليه ضد روسيا
كما ساقط دقات القمه الاوروبيه من جهتها
على تمويل مشتريات لاوكرانيا من الاسلحه
والذخيره بقيمه اوليه تصل الى مليار يورو
التمسك بالنظام الدولي المتعدد الاطراف
والقائمه على القانون الدولي يمثل مدخلا
بالنسبه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي لحجز الدعم
الدولي ضد روسيا
نؤمن بميثاق الامم المتحده والقانون
الدولي وسنتحدث عن بعض التحديات التي
نواجهها منها حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ونثمن دوركم الرياضيه خاصه في تامين اتفاق
الحبوب
حرب اوكرانيا كانت جزءا من نقاشات القمم
مع الامين العام للامم المتحده حول ازمات
الغذاء والتغير المناخي واتفاق الحبوب مع
روسيا واوكرانيا
غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا يتسبب في معاناه
شديده للشعب الاوكراني وله تاثيرات كبيره
على الصعيد العالمي
القمه الاوروبيه صادقت على قرار تمويل
مشتريات اوكرانيا من الذخيره بقيمه مليار
يورو والتمويل مشتريات مشتركه بين دول
الاتحاد لاعاده التشكيل مخزونها من
الذخيره بقيمه مليار اخرى القمه اوسط
بتحفيز صناعه الاسلحه الاوروبيه
هناك حاجه للاسراع في رفع مستوى قدرات
الانتاج الاوروبيه من الذخيره والاسلحه
لذلك نبحث سبل تحفيز الصناعات العسكريه
الاوروبيه
عده دول اوروبيه تسعى الى تشكيل محكمه
خاصه لمقاضاه جريمه العدواني وفق تسميتها
في القانون الدولي محكمه تختلف في
صلاحياتها عن محكمه الجنايات الدوليه في
بيان دعمها اوكرانيا اكدت القمه الاوروبيه
التزامها بدعم شيء اليه خاصه
لمقاضاه جريمه العدوان حسب ما ورد في
البيان الرسمي الاوروبي
نور الدين الفريد العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ونعود اليكم مجددا قال رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه بين القوات
الاوكرانيه وتحسبا لتحركات العسكريه
المقبله زادت عدد جنود الاحتياط وقامت
بتدريبهم بعدما تلقت مساعدات عسكريه كبيره
من طرف حلف الناتو
القوات الاوكرانيه دربت حوالي 200 الف
مقاتل احتياطي كما تلقت كميه كبيره من
المساعدات العسكريه من طرف حلف النيتو كما
حشدت اكثر من 80 الف عسكري حول بخموت
الهدف الرئيسي سيكون اختراقا في اتجاه
بلغراد ستحاول القوات الاوكرانيه الوصول
اليها
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه قرارا باعتقال
الرئيس بوتين عاد الجدل حول صلاحيات
المحكمه وقدرتها على تنفيذ القرار خاصه
بان هذه الخطوه تتعلق برئيس دوله نوويه
كبرى
نووي روسيا ضامن امنها وحليفها الوحيد
عقيده ولدت من رحم الحرب البارده وامتدت
لروسيا الحديثه الا ان موسكو اليوم اشهرت
سلاحها النوويه من اجل ضمان حريه رئيسها
اعتقال بوتين في المانيا مثلا يعني اعلان
الحرب على روسيا وفي هذه الحاله سنستخدم
كل امكانياتنا بما في ذلك الصواريخ التي
تستهدف البوندستاج ومكتب المستشار رد
روسيا ضد محكمه الجنايات الدوليه لم يتاخر
وتراوح بين مقاضاه المسؤولين عن القرار
وصولا الى التهديد بضرب مقرها في لاهاي
بصاروخ فرط صوتي اعتقال بوتين جاء من دون
مقدمات خاصه وان الامر لم يتعلق بجرائم
حرب ارتكبها جيشه ولا حتى شركه فاجنر بل
الامر يخص ترحيل اطفال اوكرانيين من مئه
ميتم منتشر في مناطق سيطرت عليها روسيا
وجهه الاطفال
عائلات روسيه للاصغر سنا اما البقيه فهم
معنيون ايضا بنزع النازيه سته الاف طفل
اوكراني نقلوا الى مراكز اعاده تاهيل اين
تدرس اللغه الروسيه وروايه الكرملين
للتاريخ تقول مصادر امريكيه
مذكره اعتقال بحق رئيس دوله نوويه كبرى
سابقه في التاريخ لكن فصل المحكمه في قضيه
تتعلق ببلد لا يعترف بالمحكمه بخصوص جرائم
وقعت في بلد اخر هو ايضا لا يعترف بدوره
باختصاص المحكمه حدث غير مسبوق محكمه
لاهاي اعتبرت اعلان كييف شفويا قبول
اختصاص المحكمه قبل اسابيع مبررا يوازي في
مفعوله انضمامها لاتفاقيه روما المؤسسه
تبرير وصفه الكريملين بالمهزله وهو ما
ينطبق على امريكا التي باركته ايضا وهي لا
تعترف بدورها بالمحكمه اما التحقيقات فهي
مسرحيه اعتمدت على نتائج توصلت اليها
محكمه اوكرانيه
123 دوله التزمت باتفاقيات روما لكنها لن
تكون كلها قادره على تنفيذ القرار اما
خوفا او تقديرا للصداقه التي تجمعها
بروسيا الا ان القرار يحمل ثقلا رمزيا لا
يزول بالتقادم
ومواجهته هاجس سيرافق بوتين الى اخر ايامه
في اطار استمرار القيود على صادرات الصراع
الامريكيه لاحباط تقدم بكين التكنولوجي
اضافت اداره الرئيس الامريكي اربع عشره
شركه صينيه الى قائمه العقوبات من بينها
شركه
قالت اداره بايدن ان هذه الشركات لم يتم
التحقق من انشطتها مما يجبر المصدرين
الامريكيين على تعزيز اجراءات الفحص الفني
قبل شحن البضائع الى هذه الشركات وكذا
نائب وزير التجاره الامريكي في بيان
للوزاره ان فرض الضوابط على الصادرات جزء
مهم من حمايه الامن القومي الامريكي لافتا
الى ان الاداره الامريكيه ملتزمه باستخدام
جميع الادوات المتاحه لمعرفه كيفيه
استخدام التكنولوجيا الامريكيه المتقدمه
في جميع انحاء العالم
جلسه الاستماع لرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك
التطبيق الصيني بنشر فيديو يحمل تهديدا
لرئيسه مجلس او جلسه الاستماع كما قال
الكونجرسون الحزب الشيوعي الصيني قد يخترق
هواتف الامريكيين عبر تيك توك وطلب
التطبيق المملوكه لشركه بايت دانس الصينيه
بضبط المحتوى وعدم تحوله لاداه تجسس كما
تم شركه بتزويد الحكومه الصينيه ببيانات
المستخدمين ودع الكونجرس لتقييد الوصول
الى تيك توك في الولايات المتحده فيما قال
التطبيق بانه يقوم بانتهاكات منذ فتره
طويله ويجب وقف ضررها بحسب
رئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك بشهادته امام
لجنه الطاقه والتجاره بمجلس النواب ليواجه
صله صعبه من اللجنه في ظل مخاوف اداره
بايدن من تسريب معلومات المستخدمين
الامريكيين الى الحكومه الصينيه
تيك توك يراقبنا جميعا والحزب الشيوعي
الصيني قادر على استخدام ذلك كاداه
للتلاعب بامريكا هل تؤكد ان بيدانس والحزب
الشيوعي الصيني لا يمكنهما استخدام شركتك
للترويج لرسائل الحزب والقيام بعمل عدواني
ضد تايوان
نحن لا نروج او نزير المحتوى بناء على طلب
من الحكومه الصينيه واجبنا تجاه هذه
اللجنه وكافه المستخدمين ان يبقى المحتوى
خاليا من اي تلاعب من قبل اي حكومه
انك تحاول اعطاء الانطباع بانك بعيد عن
بيكين والحزب الشيوعي انك ممثل جيد
تيك توك ما زال عالقا في صراع جيوسياسي
بين واشنطن وبكين وظهر الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه تيك توك
شوتشيو امام لجنه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
لاقناعهم بالتراجع عن مخططاتهم لحظر تطبيق
بالكامل في الولايات المتحده او اجبار تيك
توك على الانفصال عن الشركه الام باي دانس
المسؤول الصيني واجه وابلا من الاسئله من
الممثلين في اللجنه حول سياسات حمايه
البيانات وما اذا كانت ملكيه التطبيق من
قبل شركه تكنولوجيا صينيه تشكل خطرا على
الامن القومي الامريكي تشو يدخل عش
الدبابير بقدميه قريبا لكن لديه خطه
لتفادي اللدغات خلال شهادته الاولى امام
الكونجرس سلطت شو الضوء على ارشادات
السلامه الجديده لتيك توك لابعاد الانظار
عن اي ضغوط امريكيه بهدف اجبار المنصه على
تسليم خوارزميتها
[تصفيق]
وستتضمن جهود تيك توك منع المستخدمين تحت
سن السادسه عشره من ارسال رسائل مباشره
وذلك لحمايه المراهقين بالاضافه الى تكثيف
اجراءات لازاله المحتوى العنيف من المنصه
وتركز محاولات تشو لطمانه الامريكيين على
مشروع تكساس ايضا الذي يمثل وعدا بحمايه
بيانات المستخدمين الامريكيين عبر حفظ
بياناتهم في شركات محليه مثل راكل
ولكن مع كل هذه الجهود يبدو ان الولايات
المتحده ستظل دائما قلقه طالما تحتفظ بكين
بسيطرتها على تيك توك
ومن ناحيه اخرى يرى ان الصين تفضل خروج
تيك توك من السوق الامريكيه بدلا من بيعها
للولايات المتحده
ويواجه التطبيق المملوك لشركه صينيه حضره
محتملا في الولايات المتحده من جديد
وعواقب القرار المرتقبه او المرتقبه لا
تواجه الشركه الصينيه فحسب بل طالت
المعلنين ايضا
الامر الذي سيجعل هؤلاء المعلنين يراقبون
مصير ازمه تيك توك عن كثب قبل ان يقرروا
الاعلان في التطبيق
تتعرض الشركه لضغوط متزايده من مسؤولين
ونواب امريكيين بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن
القومي
وتحديدا في بيانات المستخدمين التي يرون
انها قد تقع في يد الحكومه الصينيه رغم
تاكيد الرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك ان الشركه
لم تشارك ابدا هذه البيانات وهي نفس التهم
التي تواجهها المنصه في عدد من دول اوروبا
التي قامت بحظر التطبيق جزئيا
وصف زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا ايرلابي
تصريحات رئيس الوزراء
بالاكاذيب كما تعايير لبيد اعضاء حزب
بنيامين نتنياهو الى الانشقاق عنه بعد ان
قال ان المعارضه ترفض الجلوس على طاوله
الحوار وان التعديلات القضائيه تستجيب
لمطالب كافه الاطراف
لسه كانت نحن مصممون على المضي قدما
باصلاح النظام القضائي سنتقدم وسنصحح بشكل
مسؤول لاعاده التوازن بين السلطات المسار
الافضل لتحقيق هذا الاصلاح لمنع التصدع في
الشارع هو التوصل الى توافق عريض للاسف
حتى هذه اللحظه ممثل والمعارضه رفضوا
الدخول في حوار امل ان يتغير الامر في
الايام المقبله انا اصغي لمخاوف الطرف
الاخر نحن لن نسيطر على لجنه القضاه ولكن
سنحدث توازنا وتنوعا في المحكمه والتوجهات
في اثيوبيا مشاعر يحيى السلام لا تزال
متواصله فبعد شطب البرلمان اسم الجبهه
الشعبيه لتحرير من قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه اعلن مكتب رئيس الوزراء ابي
احمد عن انشاء اداره مؤقته لمنطقه وهي
خطوه رئيسيه في عمليه السلام عقب حرب
استمرت عامين في شمال البلاد
الحوار والمصالحه ترتسم معالمها في
اثيوبيا تزامنا مع رفع جبهه تحرير من
قائمه الجماعات المصنفه ارهابيا وانشاء
اداره مؤقته للمنطقه بعد قرابه سنتين من
الحرب التي استنزفت الطرفين خطوه من شانها
تعزيز السلام والاستقرار في البلاد اذا
تمكنت الاطراف من تعميم لغه الحوار مع
كافه الجماعات المسلحه تمشيا مع بنود
الاتفاق المبرم في نوفمبر الماضي مكتب
رئيس الوزراء اليثيوبي عينه
البارزه في جبهات التحرير تيجرير رئيسا
للحكومه المؤقته وهي خطوه رئيسيه ستسمح
للجبهه بالعوده للساحه السياسيه وخلق ثقه
متبادله بين الاطراف
الاجراء وفق مراقبين للتطورات الحاصله
سيشجع اطرافا اخرى معارضه للمطالبه بازاله
اسمها عن لوائح الارهاب المحليه في
المرحله المقبله
فالكثير من الاثيوبيين يعملون في ان تدفع
هذه الخطوه الى تسريع تطبيق كافه مخرجات
اتفاق السلام المبرم في نوفمبر الماضي
ووضع الاساس الصحيح الذي يضمن العوده الى
دوله مستقره وامنه بعد ان شغل النزاع في
تيجري طيله الفتره الماضيه المجتمع
الدوليه والمحلي
الداخليه الفرنسيه على اعتقال 82 محتجا
واصابه اكثر من 130 رجل امن خلال
المظاهرات في فرنسا وزير الداخليه الفرنسي
قال انه سيتجه الى مقر شرطه باريس وانه
سيتابع وضع المظاهرات الرافضه لاصلاح
قانون التقاعد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من هنا بدات التعبئه في العاصمه الفرنسيه
يوم اسود كما وصفته النقابات التي نظمت
تظاهرات حاشده في اليوم التاسع من
الاحتجاجات الوطنيه ضد قانون التقاعد رد
المعارضه على خطاب الرئيس كان واضحا لا
تراجع حتى تحقيق المطالب بكل ما اوتيت من
قوه حشدت النقابات والاحزاب المعارضه
انصارها في الشارع الفرنسي ردا على خطاب
ماكرون الذي اعلن فيه عن دخول قانون رفع
سن التقاعد حيز التنفيذ في نهايه العام
الجاري
علينا ان نعلمه درسا بان التاريخ ليس
الرئيس من يكتبه بل الشعب والعمال انظروا
من 200 سنه في فرنسا كيف العاملون
والمواطنون هم من كتبوا التاريخ وليس
الرؤساء وكانه اعلنها حربا هكذا اتت رده
فعل متظاهرين في اليوم التاسع للحراك
الوطني لم تقتصر تحركات المحتجين على
المظاهرات المنظمه بل تعدتها الى تعطيل
نقاط رئيسيه عن الحركه في باريس قطع
متظاهرون الطريقه المؤدي الى مطار رواسي
شاردو غول في مقطع حمارون محطه قطارات
جاردو ليون وعطلوا سكتها وفي تصعيد اخر
تعدى محتجون على افراد من مركز شرطه مدينه
لوغييون ما دفع وزير الداخليه الى شجب
الاعتداء وادانته نعم زينه وهكذا انتهى
المشهد حرائق مشتعله في معظم الشوارع بعد
قيام الشرطه بتفريق المتظاهرين الذين
انتشروا في احياء العاصمه وقاموا باشعال
الحرائق لعرقله تقدم الشرطه التي كانت
تلاحقهم وقامت وزاره الداخليه بطلب
تعزيزات اضافيه من قوات الاطفاء مع
استمرار المتظاهرين باشعال الحرائق على
طول الطرق والاحياء التي يسلكونها
وبسبب عدد المتظاهرين الضخم في العاصمه لم
تتمكن الشرطه من السيطره على كل
المتظاهرين مشاهد النيران المشتعله في كل
مكان دفعت عددا كبيرا من السكان الى
التحرك ومساعده قوات الاطفاء للسيطره على
هذه النيران هذه المشاهد تذكر بازمه
السترات السفر عام 2018 لكن المعارضه باتت
تقول انها اقوى واعنف لان الرئيس صب الزيت
على النار لقناتي العربيه والحدث فادي
الدهوك باريس
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انها تحقق في
اسباب وجود ثغره في الاعتمادات الامنيه
الخاصه بنحو 250 موظفا في شركه بوينج
يعملون على طائرات رئاسه الامريكيه
الحاليه والمستقبليه وقالت القوات الجويه
الامريكيه ان جميع العاملين في بوينج
احتفظوا بالتصاريح الحاليه فائقه السريه
لكن الافراد العاملين على مسائل متعلقه
بطائرات الرئيسيه يحتاجون تصريحات امنيه
اضافيه
واضافتنا مشكله اعتمادات الامنيه لم تؤثر
على الجدول الزمني للطائرات الجديده والذي
يشير الى تسليم اول طائرتين بحلول سبتمبر
الى انخفاض نسبه تاييد رئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن الى ادنى مستوى لها تقريبا في شهر
مارس الجاري وياتي ذلك عقب المخاوف من
انهيار البنوك والصراعات الاقتصاديه
الاخرى وتبلغ نسبه تاييد جو بايدن حاليا
38% فقط وهو انخفاض كبير عن النسبه
السابقه البالغه
45% في فبراير
جهود مكثفه قامت بها سلطات السويسريه لمنع
انهيار بنك كريدي سويس ليس خوفا على احد
اكبر بنوك سويسرا فحسب ما الحفاظا على
النظام المصرفي بالكامل
اقوى ملجا
لاغاعلم
كانت سويسرا بنك العالم
صاحبه النظام المصرفي الانجح والاكثر
استقرارا حتى جاءت ازمه بنك كريدي سويس
التي هزت تلك الصوره
الازمه انطلقت يوم الخميس الماضي عندما
بدا العملاء بسحب ودائعهم لتنخفض اسهم
البنك بنسبه مخيفه وتبلغ سالب
5.48
ليرفع البنك الرايه الحمراء
الانهيار بدا يوم الخميس ولم تنتظر
السلطات السويسريه حتى انتهاء عطله نهايه
الاسبوع
لتوفر اكثر من 150 مليار دولار لكريدي
سويس الحل الامثل وربما الوحيد كان شراء
كريدس من قبل بنج اخر ليكون المنافس يو بي
اس هو من يستحوذ عليه البنك الوطني
السويسري ووزير الماليه وهيئه الاشراف على
السوق الماليه
تدخلوا بالسرعه القصوى مقدمين خيارين لا
ثالث لهما شراء
او تركه يعلن افلاسه والذي سيهوي بالبنوك
الاخرى مثل قطع الدومينو لينتهي الامر
بانهيار النظام المصرفي بالكامل
البنك الوطني السويسري باقراض بنك كريدي
سويس حجما كبيرا من السيوله وهذا الدعم
بعيد المدى يؤمن الوقت اللازم لايجاد حل
للحفاظ على الاستقرار المالي افلاس مصر
فكريدي سويس له عواقب وخيمه على الاستقرار
المالي الوطني والدولي والاقتصاد السويسري
لطالما كانت سويسرا البنك الامنه للعالم
تعتمد نظاما مصرفيا مدروسا ومستقرا ومع
اقتراب كريدي سويس من حافه الافلاس لم يكن
الخوف على البنك فقط بل على مكانه سويسرا
وانهيار نموذجها الاقتصادي المتين والذي
تعتمده الدوله المحايده بشكل اساسي الى
عمر العربيه
في رد على الى الماسك قال المدير العام
لمنظمه صحه العالميه دروس ان الادعاء بان
معاهده الوباء ستشهد تخلي الدول عن السلطه
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
ما زلنا نرى معلومات مضلله على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وفي وسائل الاعلام
الرئيسيه حول اتفاق الوباء الذي تتفاوض
عليه الدول الان كما قلت الاسبوع الماضي
فان الادعاء بان الاتفاقيه سوف تتنازل عن
السلطه لمنظمه الصحه العالميه تودع خاطئ
تماما انها اخبار مزيفه لن تتنازل اي دوله
عن اي سياده لمنظمه الصحه العالميه اذا
كان اي سياسي او رجل اعمال او اي شخص على
الاطلاق مرتبكا بشان ماهيه اتفاق الوباء
سنكون اكثر من سعداء لمناقشته وشرح ذلك
المركزيه الكوريه الرسميه ان اختبرت
منظومه جديده لهجبهه نوويه تحت الماء
بتوجيه من رئيسها
كما اكدت الوكاله للغواصه مهمتها التسببه
النطاق عبر انفجار تحت المياه لتدمير سفن
وموانئ معاويه
اعلنت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين والقطاعات
الامنيه عن اكتمال كافه الاستعدادات
والخطط التشغيليه بالحرم المكي وساحاته
بحيث سيعمل هذا العام بكامل طاقته
الاستيعابي تشهد نوعيه الخدمات قفزه من
خلال تفعيل احدث التقنيات وادخال اليات
الذكاء الاصطناعي وتسخير روبوتات الذكيه
والتطبيقات الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
من المعتمرين والمصلين يستقبلها المسجد
الحرام بعد ان اعلنت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
عن تشغيل الحرم المكي بكامل الطاقه
الاستيعابيه دون قيود طوال شهر رمضان
ويقابلها منظومه عمل موسع
[موسيقى]
هناك خطه مشتركه ابواب محدده لدخول المصلي
وابواب محدده لدخول المعتمر حتى يتم خروجه
من هذه الشعيره تقوم الرئاسه بما لديها من
مكونات ومن مستهدفات في خطتها بعرض جميع
محاور هذه الخطه حتى يقوم قاصد بيت الله
الحرام باداء نسخه بكل بكل يسر وسهوله
وبكل طمانينه خصصت رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين
اثني عشر الف موظف وعامل بالمسجد الحرام
وهيات 14 مسارا خاصا لدخول وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين الى جانب فتح كافه
التوسعات السعوديه الثلاث بالحرم المكي
وتوفير تسعه الاف عربه كهربائيه ومتحركه
للتسهيل على كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه اضافه الى تسخير التقنيات والذكاء
الاصطناعي رحله المعتمر ورحله
اكتملت جميع خدماته بمنظوماتها التكامليه
والارشاديه وغيرها بالتنسيق مع الجهات
الامنيه فيما يحقق الراحه لقاصدي بيت الله
الحرام تسعى الرئاسه من خلال كوادرها
البشريه المتفانيه بالخبرات التراكميه الى
وضع خطه تشغيليه مرنه لموسم رمضان هذا
العام مع الاخذ في الاعتبار لعوده اعداد
المعتمرين والمصلين الى ما قبل جائحه
فيروس كورونا من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
[موسيقى]
اعتاد سودانيون خلال شهر رمضان على
الاجتهاد في توفير احتياجات الشهر الفضيل
لكن هذا العام وفي ظل الظروف الاقتصاديه
الصعبه وجد المواطلون صعوبه في توفير
مستلزمات الافطار السوداني
[موسيقى]
منطقه مستلزمات المطبخ هذه بالسوق الشعبي
وسط الخرطوم جرت العاده ان تمتلئ بالباعه
والمتسوقين في شهر رمضان لاقتناء ما يميز
مائده افطار السودانيين
هذا العام حضر الباعه لكن غاب المشترون
سوق ما في يعني ممكن تنام والله في الكرسي
ساعه ساعه ونص ساعتين ممكن ثلاثه ساعات
اربعه ساعات تكون ما يجيك زبون والله
الناس يعني حتى
بيجيك تعبان يقول لك يا اخي انا والله
اشتريت حاجه
هنا ضعف القوه الشرائيه لدى المواطنين
سببا رئيسيا في ضعف الاقبال على الشراء
السنه كويسه
بالنسبه للقوه الشرعيه يعني اما بالنسبه
الشرعيه ضعيفه شويه
السودان الذي يعيش ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره
يشكو مواطنوه تعاظم الضغط عليهم خلال
الشهر المبارك
الاسعار العاليه شديد يعني اصوات تخيلناها
يعني زياده كثيره من السنه اللي فاتت يعني
اشتريت فول على اسعار زايده يشتريت
كل الحاجات بتاعه رمضان يعني
في زياده يعني خياليه يعني انا ما عارفه
الحاصل شنو في البلد دي ولا في رقيب ولا
في حسيب يعني
التكاتف ومراعاته حال عموم المواطنين عند
تسعير السلع مطالب تجد طريقها الى التجار
ضعيفه جدا جدا
وقوفه المستهلك السوداني عاجزا امام غلاء
الاسعار وشكوى التجاري من الكساد كلها
عوامل قد تجعل فوائد الصائمين هذا العام
اكثر تواضعا والمظاهر الاحتفاليه اقل فرحا
سالم الهاشمي العربي الخرطوم
فالختام هذا تذكير بالعرب
الجيش الامريكي ينفذ ضربات جويه في سوريا
ردا على هجوم سابق استهدف جنودا امريكيين
يحضر الاوروبيين بان التاخر في ارسال
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا سيطيل امد الحرب
الولايات المتحده تفرض قيودا على اربعه
عشر شركه صينيه تستورد
اعتقال اثنين وثمانين محتجا في باريس
واصابه اكثر من 130 عنصر امن لمظاهره
مليونيه قدام قانون التقاعد
[موسيقى]
شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء